en france la polémique que s'amplifie
autour du projet de loi actuellement
étudiés au parlement sur l'immigration
est principalement sur les conditions
d'hébergement d'un étranger il ya soir
sur france 2 dans l'émission bouillon de
culture de bernard pivot un débat assez
vif a permis d'entendre des positions
respectives des uns qui sont pour et des
autres qui sont contre pascal doucement
nous réalisateur français déclarant nous
sommes coupables chacun d'entre nous
d'avoir c'est la deuxième partie de
l'émission bernard pivot lille appelle
des cinéastes contre le projet de loi
debré le débat précédent concerné
châteauvallon c'est au tour des
pétitionnaires de parler et l'on
découvre non pas une opposition
systématique au projet dans son ensemble
mais une attaque ciblée contre
l'obligation de signaler le départ de
l'étranger héberger la confusion entre
les gens qui sont clandestins qui
viennent travailler clandestinement que
moi je je sais c'est pas du tout des
choses que je que j'approuve et on fait
la confusion entre des clandestins aidés
et des immigrés des étrangers qui sont
en france nous on veut pas faire
douaniers c'est quelque chose la
déclaration d'hébergement s'est tout
d'un coup quelque chose qui nous met
dans une position
à l'intérieur de notre vie privée à
l'intérieur du lieu où on est chez nous
on se trouve dans une situation
pas de délation en tout cas de
déclaration
la protestation est donc très précise et
apparemment elle trouve l'écho le plus
inattendu c'est le coup de théâtre de la
soirée guy sorman vous qui êtes au
cabinet du premier ministre et nous dira
si je ne mets crus comme en nom
personnel mais je crois que c'est
également le sentiment du premier essai
qui a effectivement un article de trop
et philippe douste-blazy présent il hier
n'a pas contredit guy sorman compte
aujourd'hui matignon dément les propos
de son conseiller et rappelle que le
projet de loi sera devant l'assemblée le
25 février prochain comment alors calmé
la colère des pétitionnaires sans donner
du grain à moudre à l'extrême droite
l'émission d'hier était une chronique
d'un d amorçage probable mais surtout
d'une gêne à peine dix ans